so I just got back from the Apple Store
and I'm pretty excited because this was
the last pair of air pods that they had
in the store they started shipping a few
days ago but today was the day that they
were in the store I guess there was a
big line of people this morning see
here's the nice little box I think it's
uh it's nice it's um square are you
ready for this
here they are why isn't this USBC okay
so here's the air pods as you can see
here this is where you'll charge them
okay time to set these up got my phone
and basically you're just supposed to
open these up and they should
automatically connect that was freakin
fast connecting connecting dot that
that's it
that's it so on this screen it gives you
a percentage of how charged your air
pods are and how charged the charging
dock is oops I closed it
I didn't mean to close it as soon as I
open it that popped up that's fast let's
take them out and this is gonna be the
real test okay
they already feel like they're falling
out Oh yep I'm gonna push this in as far
as I can get I'm gonna play a song let's
modify and see boom it sounds good
though we lock let's lock one
okay I'm sorry fall out fall out
I'm shaking my head pretty hard
silly earrings it it looks like I've got
some super stylish earrings hey Siri
what do you think of the air pods
okay well that worked pretty quickly hey
Siri can you tell me what the weather's
gonna be like today so my initial
thoughts these are not gonna stay in my
ears very well and a little bit upset
about it they basically are exactly he
like the same shape as the ear pod I
feel like I need just a little something
else to help these stay in my ears
I have maybe weird shaped ears I'm not
sure but I am surprised at how well they
actually are staying in because I
thought they would fall out immediately
as soon as they put them in
I love the case it's really well
designed I love that I can just throw
these in here like here we go oh okay
well in in charge I'm gonna be traveling
tomorrow so I will let you guys know how
these work out for me on the plane the
one thing that I'm gonna be nervous
about is losing them I'm gonna be super
super scared it looks like like a little
lighter hey you got a light no but I've
got air pods let me know what you guys
think I will give you an updated review
as I've used them a little bit longer
but my initial reaction is I think that
I will be able to use these I've been
traveling a lot and just using the
lightning cable ear pods that come with
my phone so I've kind of been training
my ears and preparing them for the air
paws
wish me luck guys see you guys the next
video yeah
which new under your team I think it's a
perfectly wanna sweat he wishes sweat
can we switch